well was it was a terrible weekend in
America and there's there's really no
other way to put it I'm sure a lot of
you had a similar experience to me I
went to bed on Saturday night thinking
about the shooting in El Paso that
claimed 20 lives as it stands right now
20 maybe that will go up because there
dozens were injured as well some still
in the hospital went to bed on Saturday
night thinking about that horrible thing
wake up in the morning go online I see
people talking about a mass shooting it
takes me a couple of minutes to realize
they're not talking about El Paso
they're talking about Dayton there was
another mass shooting while I was
sleeping you know less than 12 hours
after the first one in the span of 12
hours we had two mass shootings what I
want to do today as we're discussing
this well let me tell you first what I
don't want to do what I don't want to do
is say the same things that we always
say the same things that I always say I
don't want to give you talking points in
bumper sticker slogans there's there's
no point in that because we all get it I
don't want to make this a simple left
versus right thing because it's not and
because there's something just so Hollow
and empty about that game so devoid of
humanity is that that game the the the
simple partisan political game that we
play with dead bodies after something
like this and it's that you know I call
it Hollow and empty I think it's even
worse than that really because nobody
will ever admit this no one's ever gonna
admit feeling this way but I detected
I'm pretty sure real Glee coming from
some people after the El Paso shooting
when it turned out that the El Paso
shooter was a white nationalist Trump
fan you know someone that the left could
pin on the right and among some leftists
on social media at least based on their
social media posting there's no
indication of anything like sadness or
mourning or anything it was just see see
this is you see it's Trump I told you
see that's what it seemed like they were
really happy they were happy it seemed
as though they were happy it happened
some of them because
they could something they could use now
against the other side for them it
became automatically just a thing to use
again just a just ammo in a in a you
know in an argument and then on Sunday
when it turned out that the Dayton
shooter seemed to seem to be a
self-described leftist supported
Elizabeth Warren and Tifa according to
hit what he posted on social media again
it seemed like some on the right there
was real Glee real happiness like that
no mourning no no sadness at sea no this
one's on you I got you now Seenu no this
is your fault in so many words right not
quite using those words but almost it's
just so sickening that you know it these
are human beings this is a real people
who die this isn't just some thing to
argue about it's a real human tragedy in
fact you could see even in real time as
the narrative shifted on both sides
it was interesting on Saturday morning
watching as some conservatives insisted
that the politics of the El Paso shooter
didn't matter
while people on the Left were saying oh
it does matter and then with the Dayton
shooter now all the sudden there are
some people on the right side no no no
now it now politics do meadow didn't
matter before now they do yeah yeah
yesterday morning
didn't matter now it does and then
people on the Left though shifted and
when they were saying yesterday oh the
politics matter and now on Sunday they
say no no it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it's just the hypocrisy on both
sides is is disgusting and the thing is
the people on both sides will justify
this kind of hypocrisy this kind of
double-talk this kind of manipulation
this kind of game playing
they played political games with the
bodies of murdered women and children
and men and they justify it by saying
well the other side is doing it they're
doing it too and it'll say well we have
to do it so we can win win what what are
you winning what do you think you're
winning what contests do you win by
giving up your soul okay
when you when you when you
forfeit your humanity when you become
nothing but this partisan machine that
just sees everything immediately through
the lens of how can I use this to win an
argument when you become that what do
you think you've won because you've
given up yourself your soul your
humanity
you're nothing anymore you're just a
you're just this thing you're just this
zombie and you think you win that way
what do you think you've won you've won
nothing let me tell you something if
you're so worried about the other side
well when when her the other side from
their perspective since you've given up
your humanity and your soul they that's
a win for them and so if you care so
much about winning the minute you become
an unthinking human partisan machine
capable of only seeing anything in
partisan terms the minute that happens
you lose I mean you lose everything
literally everything you lose you lose
yourself
okay so congrats you're a good
Republican you're a good Democrat nicely
done but you're a bad human is that a
trade worth making it's like we all
think now well yeah I could be a bad
person but as long as I'm a good member
of my party it's fine so what I want to
do today is I want to try to get beyond
that
and not use these strategies tragedies
to support talking points because
there's no point anyway I mean even if I
were gonna do that you already know
everything i if I'm gonna do that then
everything I say you already think that
it's just a no point even saying really
right so rather than do that what I want
to try to do is investigate which what
kind of factors are really driving this
epidemic of mass shootings and I think I
have and I don't have the answer okay if
there is the answer out there I don't
have it I'm not smart enough for that
but I do have I think some answers a few
answers and I want to talk about those
today but before I do you know in order
for this show to exist we need to we
need support from our sponsors and
that's why and that's just the reality
right and so that's what I want to start
by thanking the sponsor today's show
stamps.com
you know no one really has time to go to
the post office you're busy who's got
time for all
traffic you're gonna you're going out
it's just it's just we got a million
things to do it's a it's a whole big
hassle so that's why you need stamps
calm one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps calm
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts that you
can't even get at the post office stamp
com brings all the amazing services of
the u.s. post office writes your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices and online seller
shipping out products or even a
warehouse setting thousands of packages
a day whatever the case is stamps.com
will handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
packages 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it once your mail is ready you just
stick it in the mailbox give it to your
letter carrier and it's as simple as
that right now my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in Walsh
that's stamps com enter Walsh and start
saving time and money today
alright so what can we say about this
what could actually be causing the mass
shootings you know what we know is that
nine of the last nine of the top of
twelve or thirteen worst mass shootings
in history deadliest best shooting in
history that have happened in the past
twelve years just a little over a decade
we've had nine of the of the top
deadliest mass shootings ever five of
the deadliest mass shootings have
happened in the past seven years three
of the five deadliest have happened in
the last three years now if you expand
this a little bit look at it look at a
you know the bigger picture you're gonna
find that something like a sixteen or I
don't have the exact 16 or 17 of the top
27 deadliest shootings in American
history have been in the last 12 or 13
years if you're a millennial like me
almost all of the worst mass shootings
in American history have happened in
your lifetime except maybe two or three
of them now these statistics matter okay
it's true that when you hear from the
media yeah well you'll hear from the
media this week what you always hear is
is that there
hundreds of mass shootings every year in
fact I just read an article I forget
where I read it but the article claimed
that there were 250 mass shootings just
this year alone 250 already which of
course is a is a grossly inflated number
and grossly in in multiple meanings of
the term therefore gross it's an extreme
inflation it's also gross just it's
disgusting to try to inflate the numbers
of mass shootings when it's already bad
enough like you don't need to pump up
the statistics it's bad already
so no 250 249 in a year no it's it's
that's not what we're talking about
because in order to get to that number
they're counting any shooting where four
or more people are injured or killed so
it doesn't have to be to count to this
statistic you don't even even if nobody
was killed
it's still called a mass shooting and
they include things like gang shootings
drug-related violence domestic violence
all of that is bad obviously anytime
someone's killed it's a terrible thing
all of those are problems nobody denies
that but it's not the same thing as
somebody walking into a crowded place in
suburbia somewhere or into a school and
shooting everybody in sight that's a
different sort of thing from domestic
violence and certainly from gang
shootings which again are bad and that's
a that's that's an issue unto itself
which we've been talking about
especially the last few weeks but you
can also easily think about a gang
shooting is that you can easily sort of
avoid most of the time being shot in a
gang shooting if you don't if you don't
engage in gang-related activity if you
don't sell drugs you're probably not
going to be you the likelihood of you
being a victim of a drug-related
drive-by is decreased substantially by
just not selling drugs right the thing
that makes it and when we hear about
mass shootings that's not what we think
about we think about the sort of thing
that happened in Dayton Ohio or in El
Paso the thing that makes those so scary
is that those can happen anywhere and
these people weren't doing anything
risky or dangerous they were just going
about their day they were shopping they
were going out to eat they were going to
are just normal things and next thing
you know it turns into a bloodbath
so it's this specific sort of shooting
that is mostly a modern phenomenon
obviously people being killed murder is
not a modern phenomenon that's been
going on since the dawn of time but this
specific sort of incident has gotten a
lot worse in recent years yes you're
still probably more likely to die from a
shark attack than to die in a mass
shooting that's true but we're at the
point now where a few times a year
something like this happens and it
hasn't always been that way it hasn't
always been that common I just gave you
the statistics to have nine of the top
12 deadliest mass shootings in just the
last 11 or 12 years that is that that
that's that's incredible that is an
incredible fact that we shouldn't just
get used to or say yeah you know okay
but still overall the murder numbers are
down not talking about overall numbers
this is a problem it shouldn't be like
this we shouldn't take it for granted it
should when I remember being a kid I
remember when Columbine happened and it
was it was a it was the only thing
anyone talked about for months on end
because no one had ever heard of
anything like this happening before and
now it's it's you know these mass
shootings by Wednesday we won't even be
talking about them anymore because we're
so used to it and that is a problem
obviously now if just to put this in
perspective imagine for a second that
that rather than having these mass
shootings that were so common imagine
that they were serial killings okay
imagine that that twice a year a
different serial killer murdered 15 or
16 people in a string of murders imagine
that that is serial killers that
prolific were that common that it was
two or three times a year you had you
know one of the worst men imagine that
almost every year now we have one of the
worst serial killers in history pops up
now if that were the case we would all
be saying yeah I mean your likelihood of
being killed by a serial killer is still
very very low but what's going on how
could this be so calm enough
how are we producing so many serial
killers in in comparison to two times in
the past well it's the same thing with
mass killings it's just a mass killings
the same thing basically it's just that
you kill everybody all at once rather
than one at a time so it's the same
thought sort of thing where we we have
to ask ourselves why is this happening
what what explains why it's so
commonplace now we all know the usual
suspects right the usual things we blame
guns mental illness ideology all of
those things are relevant but what I
said is I want to talk about this
without without focusing on those things
we always talk about so so I'm not gonna
focus on those even though it's relevant
now in many cases the mass shooters they
obtain their guns illegally or they're
using guns that aren't theirs they're
using their parents guns or something
like that and it's true that they should
be prevented from using those guns but
that often involves enforcing laws that
are already on the books so when it
comes to guns if we just enforce the
laws that are already on the books we
would have prevented a number of these
already just from the existing law it's
we don't need to add more laws we just
need to enforce the laws that are
already on the books we have a ton of
laws in this country
why are from from we our law our law
book if you were to just look at a book
with every law listed in it in every
state included it would be thousands and
thousands of pages on there are tons of
laws we don't need more of them we just
the laws that are on the books need to
be enforced the Dayton shooter
apparently had a hit list when he was in
high school he was caught with a hit
with a hit list and a rape list of
people who wanted to kill at people who
wanted to rape he was suspended from
school for now every sane person agrees
that if you have a hit list and it's
known that you have hit list you
shouldn't be able to buy a gun I think
every sane person agrees with that I
mean I'm a big Second Amendment advocate
but if you're telling me it should be
illegal for someone with a hit list to
buy a gun I totally agree obviously I
agree I'd be crazy not to agree with
that but it should already be possible
with the laws on the books to prevent
someone who's known to have it lists
from buying a gun and at the very least
if it's if it's difficult to just
a few tweaks to the existing laws should
make it possible now I don't know I
think we still don't know exactly how
this guy got his guns or why he was able
to get them even though he was known to
have the hit list maybe it's because he
was a minor so they could so maybe we
make some adjustments to the laws that
already exist that's fine
but even by doing that it's not gonna
solve the problem and it still raises
the question why are there so many
people and you forget about for a second
how they get their hands on the gun why
are there so many people who want to do
this in the first place you know when
you get to the point where someone is
looking for the opportunity to kill lots
of people they really want to do it and
they're gonna do it they're only now
they're just looking for a place to do
it and they're looking for the tool to
do it with when you get to that point
that's bad news we need to figure out
how do we stop people from getting to
that point how are they getting there to
begin with so I don't think focusing on
guns is the key it's true no mental
illness it's true that many of these
people suffer meant for mental illnesses
of some kind and it's true that
sometimes ideology is a factor and and
where it is you know we should look at
that the El Paso shooter was a white
nationalist who wanted to kill Mexicans
to stop them from invading the country
according to him he made that clear in
his manifesto that's that's that's a
that's something we need to look at this
is the third white nationalist mass
murder incident in just the past several
months so white nationalist terrorism is
a problem a big problem and it needs to
be named condemned and dealt with no
question there's no downplaying this
again three of the worst mass shootings
ever have happened at the hands of a
white nationalist in the past few months
okay so that's something we need to look
at for sure but here's here's the thing
there have always been guns in this
country and a lot of them and in fact
prior to I think 1986 machine guns
weren't even banned
okay machine guns are banned right now
and these these shootings are not being
carried out by
chain guns 30 or 40 years ago 40 years
ago it wasn't illegal on a federal level
any way to buy a machine gun yet these
kinds of things weren't happening
mounted mental illness we've always had
mental illness okay and if you're saying
that there's more of it now that people
are more mentally ill or more people are
mentally ill than were before well now
you've just punted the ball back because
now we have to ask well why is that the
case so just focusing on mental illness
doesn't doesn't it won't get you to the
to the root of the problem racism and
ideology again all of that existed and
certainly at least in this country
racism was worse 40 years ago than it
was today now you could argue that
racists of today like the El Paso
scumbag feel desperate and powerless
which leads them to these kinds of acts
as opposed to the races of the past who
lived in a society that was tailor-made
for their racism a society where their
racist fantasies were actually enacted
in the real world where the people they
were racist against legally were not
treated as equal we're not even treated
as human and so you could say that
wealthy or racist back then you had less
incentive to go out and carry out these
acts as opposed to the racist of today
and and there's probably troops that but
but the fact is again racism has always
existed there's always been violent
ideologies and you know the those top
nine worst mass shootings in US history
that have happened recently only one of
them two of them I think had anything to
do with with race and if you were to
look at the top you know 30 mass
shootings in American history again
you're gonna find that a small minority
of them were were motivated by race and
in fact a small minority of them were
motivated by any kind of discernible
ideology whatsoever so I think if we
want to understand the current epidemic
we have to look at factors that are
themselves current see that makes sense
to me if we're noticing that this
problem is getting worse
in modern times especially in the last
10 or 20 years then it makes sense to
look and see okay what has changed in
society
in the last 10 or 20 years or the last
20 or 30 years even
so let me that's what I want to do now I
want to look at contributing factors
that are recent that may then be more
directly correlated with the mass
shooting epidemic let's look at some of
those number one the Internet okay I
think the effect the Internet has on our
culture and on us psychologically as
people as individuals is something that
we haven't even begun to understand or
appreciate the Internet has certainly
caused a massive massive shift in the
way that we operate as people in the way
that we see the world in the way that we
interact with the world
now obviously the internet can't cause
someone to go out and be a mass shooter
the only thing that can cause directly
someone to be a mass shooter is their
own choice their own free will and
volition which is why if we're looking
at who to blame directly the only person
who gets direct immediate blame for a
mass shooting is the mass shooter right
not Donald Trump not not Republicans not
Democrats the mass shooter but if we're
looking for contributing factors then I
think obviously the Internet is going to
be one of them absolutely the more time
we spend online the more detached we
become from reality from from the world
from each other it seems you know I'm
obviously not the first person to point
this out it's become almost a cliche to
say yeah you know the more connected we
are the more disconnected we are and
people that want to sound profound make
those observations all the time but in
fact you know what
that is a profound observation even if
it's a cliche even if we all recognize
it it's profoundly true actually and not
something we should just gloss over it's
like we have trouble now recognizing
people other people as people in fact on
the internet we get used to seeing
people as just words on a screen right
because I
what they are you know we back before
the internet you know you could only
really interact unless you got on the
phone someone you were only really
interacting with people that are
directly directly around you when you're
interacted with someone directly around
you you it's harder to get around the
fact that they're a person when they're
right there in your line of sight and
they're a physical person right you got
their body language you got a you could
see everything they're right there next
to you it's harder to get around the
fact that they are people but when
you're just putting something out there
on the Internet especially when you're
not even talking to anyone directly
you're just sort of putting it out there
for everyone to see it's a lot easier to
become detached from the fact that other
actual people that you are communicating
with actual other people and that's that
this is an attitude that you find I
think the people don't even don't even
realize they have it's like what you
know well when I just began the show
talking about how awful people are on
social media after these mass shootings
and anytime I talk about something like
that people are always gonna say to me
oh well that's just Twitter that's just
the internet get off the internet is in
and you'll see that's not real life
people aren't like that in the real
world well what do you mean those are
actual humans on the internet saying
those things expressing their views so
when someone says well yeah you know you
get a lot of hate mail on the internet
people are awful they say often that's
not the real that's not the real world
what are you talking about though it's
this isn't these aren't yeah there are
some BOTS on the internet there aren't
real people but for the most part these
are real people that are that are
expressing what they really think it is
the real world actually it's like if you
know if someone wrote you a letter and
said awful things in a letter on a piece
of paper and gave it to you and you were
upset by it would it make any sense for
me to say it's not the real world's just
paper well yeah obviously the paper
isn't the thing saying the bad thing but
those ideas were expressed by a person
yet we get so used to this well if it
happens on the internet it doesn't count
and I think then what you have are
people who you know they'll go on the
internet and they'll say awful things to
people kill yourself I hope you get
cancer I hope your children die again
we're so used to seeing that kind of
stuff on the internet and and there are
millions of people who act this way on
the Internet and they tell themselves
that it's okay because it's just the
Internet but it's not morally there's no
difference at all between saying someone
in a youtube comment section kill
yourself and saying it to their face in
fact it's worse on the comment section
because you're a coward on top of it but
I think we get so accustomed that way to
treating people that way that that that
eventually it does bleed over into you
know into three-dimensional space when
you get so used to just being an awful
person and treating people terribly and
being you know at a certain point I
guess this is a point when you're a
sociopath on the Internet
it may be possible for a while to be a
sociopath on the internet and act like a
normal person in quote the real world in
three-dimensional space eventually
though so you're not gonna be able to
keep up that double life that split
personality forever eventually you're
either gonna start being a decent person
on the internet or more likely what
happens is that you end up being a
sociopath in quote the real world also
and so I think that's part of the
problem number two 24-hour cable news
you know the problem with 24-hour cable
news is twofold for one thing it makes
every mass shooting into a whole big
television event and thereby encourages
mass shooters to do this because they're
looking for attention they're looking
for infamy and they know they're gonna
get it so we all know that part of it
right we point that out all the time
the second thing though the slightly
less discussed element here is that
24-hour news encourages us again to be
detached from reality it encourages us
to see these shootings like their TV
shows like it's a plotline on Law &
Order or something
what do cable news come these channels
always do anytime there's a big tragedy
they have they have a graphic for it
they have theme music you know they do a
little
they bring in all the different analysts
they go they go on site even though
there's no reason for them to be on site
whatsoever recording you're doing a show
yeah you send a reporter out but you
don't need to bring the anchor out and
have a table set up and have them have
analyst check you don't need to be on
site for that at all but you're just
there because it just it makes for more
engaging television and so with the
cable news channels are doing is that
they're trying to turn these real human
tragedies into engaging entertaining
television events now they would never
say they're trying to make it
entertaining and the people that are at
these cable news channels they're not
directly in their head thinking how
we're gonna make this entertaining it's
just they're doing their job and the
fact is they need you to watch and and
they need ratings and so they're gonna
do the things that are gonna up those
ratings and after a while you know when
you get used to seeing murder and
tragedy and mayhem and chaos as
entertainment as a television event I
think it's gonna further that detachment
so that's an issue and again recent
internet and cable news both are very
recent things that didn't exist you know
up until the last couple of decades at
least we're not nearly as ubiquitous up
until the last 20 years or so number
three broken homes broken homes have
always existed there's always been
divorced there's always been deadbeat
dads and so on but as almost everyone
knows if that problem has gotten worse
in the last few decades and we now have
two generations of people my generation
in the next generation who a wide swaths
of people those generations are have
grown up in or did or or are growing up
in homes that you know there's no father
present the marriage is is is broken or
falling apart they're living amidst
emotional turmoil
and that obviously plays a factor here
if you look at these mass shooters now
these the two recent scumbags I don't
know maybe they both come from intact
homes I'm not sure but if you look at
them you're gonna find that a
disproportionate number of them come
from divorced families that is that's
not a coincidence
again that doesn't mean that if you get
divorced your kids are automatically to
become mass shooters it's just a kid
this we're talking about contributing
factors think of it like like a you know
like an avalanche like a snowball going
down the mountains just one thing after
another after another and eventually you
end up with a huge deadly avalanche the
fourth thing psychiatric drugs okay we
know that dozens of violent attacks in
schools have been carried out by kids on
or withdrawing from psychiatric drugs
and but not just kids and not just
schools the Las Vegas shooter was on
anxiety medicine the Colorado theater
shooter was on antidepressants of
Charleston shooter was on psychiatric
drugs the Virginia Tech shooter was on
psychiatric drugs many and again the
most recent ones we don't know but we're
not going to be surprised to find out if
it is the case that they were on some
kind of medication or just came off of
it now defenders of these drugs will
claim that well you know you can't draw
a straightforward connection between
psychotropic drugs and violent or
suicidal behavior and that's true now we
know that these drugs leave a lasting
mark on the brain but we don't know
exactly what sort of mark they leave or
how long it will last or how it might
manifest itself as a pediatric
psychologist Ronald Brown he said this
was his quote he said the there's more
use of psychotropic medication with
children than there is research data on
it in other words we'll use it we're
using it more than you know we there's
greater use of it than there is
knowledge of it as opposed as is the way
to put it would seem to me that the lack
of data about this stuff is reason
enough to pull way back I'm not saying
never use it I'm not saying there's
nobody out
who's a good candidate for psychotropic
drugs but the the use of these drugs has
skyrocketed in recent years even though
we know so little about it or how it
affects people now you know the side
effects for these drugs if you look on
the bottom it'll say things like
suicidal thoughts
you know violent or erratic behavior
that kind of thing and it says oh well
if you experience that if your kid
experiences that go talk to a doctor
well think about what we're dealing with
drugs here that according even to this
to the bottle itself even to the side
effects we're dealing with drugs that
can put thoughts in your head that's
always freaked me out when you see a
drug that has suicidal thoughts as a
side effect well how does that work
exactly you're telling me that this drug
if I take it you could make me think
something not only make me think
something it could make me think that I
want to destroy myself okay for the
third time I'm not saying we should
never take a drug with a side effect
like that there may be occasions where
it's you know we're where it's justified
but we are we're just we're dealing with
something that is pretty mysterious the
relationship between consciousness and
the brain where exactly your
consciousness comes from what exactly
neurologically drives somebody to do
these kinds of things we don't know that
exact we know very little about that
that's still a mystery to science and I
think it will always remain a mystery to
some extent because I think the answer
is not completely scientific but
regardless and yet we're shoving these
drugs and the kids faces and when you
know when you when you're given a drug
to someone and a known side effect is
that it could make them destructive or
suicidal and then they go and they act
destructively and suicidally I feel like
that's probably
not a coincidence the last thing and
this in this kind of maybe summarizes
everything else is nihilism now with
this one also nihilism is not new
there's always been nihilus out there
there's always been a tendency in some
people towards nihilism but nihilism now
has become a way of life it's become
although although unnamed most of the
time most nihilists won't call
themselves nihilists and probably many
of them probably not even know the term
means but it's it's it's really the most
mainstream philosophy in our culture
today it's how our culture operates
there is a general purpose lessness in
our society people don't know why
they're here what they're for why any of
it matters the most essential question
that we can ask ourselves a question
that human beings have been asking
themselves since the dawn of time since
the dawn of human civilization is why am
I here what am I supposed to do what am
I for what are people for it's the name
of oh it's the name of a great essay
collection by by a wendell berry and
that's that's a question what are people
for what am I for people don't have
answers to that and atheists get mad
when you point to godlessness and
nihilism purposelessness as a cause or a
factor in these things and they say well
just because I'm an atheist doesn't mean
I'm gonna go kill people yeah that's
true and they'll also point out that
many of these mass killers are not
atheist in fact probably most of them
aren't are aren't officially you know
announced atheists and that's true too
but in those are fair points but it's
also true profoundly true that people
need a sense of transcendent purpose in
their life they need a sense of of the
transcendent and if they don't have that
if we don't have that as people then
we're lost
okay so combine all these factors and
you can throw in that the the first
three that I kind of skipped over
because what we always talked about
you get but if you have someone from a
broken home from with a history of
living at home of emotional chaos and
abuse and abandonment and neglect put
them on the internet for hours a day you
know maybe maybe start shoving some
psychiatric drugs into their into their
head have them watching cable news
watching the other mass shooters and
seeing the the infamy and notoriety that
those other mass shooters attain get
them used to watching mass killings as
as if it's some sort of entertainment
and then you throw in maybe an extremist
ideology you throw in a little bit of
racism some hatred you throw in laws
that are not being enforced that make it
easier for them to attain deadly weapons
when they shouldn't be able to even
according to the laws we already have on
the books put all that together and it's
not hard to see how we end up where we
are right now so what's the solution
well as I said I don't have the one
solution I don't think there's a flip we
can switch or a switch we can flip
rather I should say there's not a switch
we could flip and just and just boom
like turning off the lights and it's and
we've solved the problem obviously that
doesn't exist but I think we could look
this solution is going to be something
it's not gonna be it's not gonna be easy
it involves massive cultural shifts and
also massive shifts in our own lives so
that we don't end up like this ourselves
and our children don't end up like this
and I say we don't end up like this I
know you might say well I would never do
this and I believe you wouldn't I
wouldn't either
but you know the fact is all of these
people that go out and commit mass
shootings I'm sure at some point in
their life many of them they also would
have said I would never do that
but they end up spiraling and going into
a very dark place because of a lot of
these factors I think and so if we
aren't worried about ourselves at the
very least we you know we should be
worried about the next generation about
our kids and their and our kids friends
and you know so we need to look at all
these things and so it's going to
involve little things like don't spend
as much time on the Internet don't spend
as much time watching cable news as as
adults we can keep our marriages
together give our kids a good a good
home life be very careful about the
drugs we put them on discover a real
purpose in life and instill that sense
of purpose in our kids all those things
I think if we did even just those three
four things I just mentioned if we did
that from here on out I think this
problem would almost completely go away
I mean you could change not a single law
you could change nothing else but if we
just made a few changes less time on the
Internet keep our families and marriages
together sense of purpose just that
three things this problem would almost
completely go away all right let me get
to a couple of emails before we wrap
things up here this is Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com is the email address this
is from QB says Matt advising people to
be paranoid in public places and calling
mass shootings routine is deeply
irresponsible fear-mongering
you said on Twitter that white
supremacist have killed 80 people
globally in the last 10 months that's
about a hundred people per year on
average out of a population of roughly
7.5 billion that's less than lightning
fatalities these incidents are not so
much as relatively routine and to call
them that is absolutely annoying and
accurate causing panic is a no way
conducive to your stated goal of limited
government as every expansion of
government has called for in response to
a panic stopping millions of Americans
go out every day and even the Washington
Post admits that only 1,700 Americans
killed in mass shooting since 1966
that's fewer than peanuts have killed
stop the fear-mongering it's sickening
all right
QB well then and he's referencing I said
on Twitter that we need to have
situational awareness when you go out in
public first of all you should protect
yourself defend yourself be able to
protect in defenders give yourselves and
yourself the means to do that but also
look when I go out in public with my
kids especially I took my kids to the
theater to the movie theater the other
day and you better believe I took note
of where the exits are I made sure to
sit close to them I made sure I had a
pass to them and when I whenever I go
into a crowded public place especially
with my kids and I admit that me for me
I'm in a slightly different position
from from other people and that you know
there are people out there who know who
I am and don't like me and so that gives
me even more reason to be aware but even
aside even if I didn't do this for a
living I would still be situationally
aware and I would recommend the same for
others now QB doesn't like that he says
that he says that's that's being
paranoid I don't think it's being
paranoid now as I said yes there there
are statistically your chances of being
killed in the mass shooting are very low
fine but you can't get around the fact
QB that as I've been talking about nine
of the deadliest mass shootings in in
American history that's 250 years of
history 9 of the worst ones have
happened in the last decade almost okay
you can't just that yeah whatever
so you accuse me of paranoid
fear-mongering I accuse you of just
waving your hand at it like AG you're
not only worried about it that's what
you're saying right don't worry about it
I think that's irresponsible and
reckless
why shouldn't you at least be aware of
your surrounding are you actually
telling me that it's irresponsible for
me to tell people to be aware of their
surroundings it's irresponsible to call
for a responsibility come on I think you
need to wake up and realize just because
it's still very unlock there could be a
disease that wipes out 10% of the
American population and it would still
have a 90% chance of not
dying from it okay you're still a very
good chance if there was a flu epidemic
that that took down 10% of the American
population the chances of you being
among that percent are you know you well
you have a 90% chance of it not being
you about a 1 what if what if what if 1%
of the population was wiped out by some
sort of pandemic well you still a 99%
chance that you're not among that that's
still a lot of people and it's still a
huge problem and it's still something
you should be aware of and if it's a
disease you know do little things like
wash your hands and just be careful and
you've got these mass shootings
happening everywhere in the country yeah
it probably won't be you it could be
though so just be aware this is
something look I agree that we shouldn't
inflate the numbers I did at the
beginning the show high stipulated as
people say 250 mass shootings in a year
well if you define it in a certain way
than yeah but if you're if you're if
we're talking about the kind of mass
shootings that we all think of when we
say mass shootings then no it's not
anywhere close to 250 in a year if we
get to that point where it's 250 of this
kind of mass shooting in a year then
that's just the end of American
civilization completely that's that's
the you know it's probably the end of
human civilization if it's that if it's
that come so yes I agree that we should
inflate the numbers and it's good to
point it out but I think that some
people on the right some conservatives
have a tendency to go way to the other
extreme and just deny that it's even a
problem and and say that it's yeah
and I think that's really stupid also
and and it seems like you're just sort
of stepping over the dead bodies because
you're worried that it would be
politically inconvenient if you
acknowledge it and so it comes across QB
like incredible political cowardice all
right um let's see here
do one more do have anything that's not
related to the shooting this is from no
I don't so I'll just do one more this is
from Erica says I'm at something you
tweeted this weekend really resonated
with me how you always check your
nearest exits when you go places and
especially with your children I do the
exact same thing but also I can't help
but have this fear when I'm in confined
spaces with my kids where I'm hardly
focused on what's going on who is
entering and leaving the exits I really
go to the movies I rarely go to movies
but even when I do I'm constantly
looking over at the entrance ISM and
someone is just standing over by the
hallway to the exit I find myself just
staring at that person wondering if he
or she is plotting to hurt everyone and
obviously the rational part of my brain
knows that the likelihood of that
occurring is just so small but I feel
like this is my life now now I'm pro-gun
but also as a parent I want some sort of
action taken maybe an armed guard or
police officer at major buildings and
churches I don't know the solution but
as far as I could tell gun laws haven't
changed but clearly there are more evil
and mentally disturbed individuals now
and honestly I feel like it's removing
God from everything people say you don't
need God or religion to know good versus
bad but I argue that that's how we've
been living for the past thirty years
and look what's happened what does a
real solution look like to you how can
we stop these events for having well of
course I just talked about what I
consider to be some solutions and okay
so we've got two sides of this issue
about you should we be aware of our
surroundings and maybe to kind of
extreme sides QB says I don't worry
about it at all whatever Erika admits
that I think she's sort of the mist that
she's got some real paranoia no I don't
think that every time someone enters a
room or standing there and near an exit
we need to be worried they're about to
kill people but just just awareness so
look I was at we were at a theater a
couple years ago and some somebody
walked into the theater a guy by himself
walked into the theater with a bag you
know like a big a big book bag and so
that's a sit my wife and I would kind of
looked at each other and thought what's
he doing here with a big book how did he
even get into here with a book bag you
can't even bring that stuff into a movie
theater so so we went and told security
and it turned out that I don't know you
probably was just trying to sneak snacks
and was it try to get him in trouble
right I mean if you want to sneak snacks
and go ahead
all the time to be honest but that's the
kind of thing that's out of place and I
think that's the sort of thing we should
be aware of it's the same thing they
tell you the airport's just be aware you
know if you see someone leave their
luggage and go and walk away from your
luggage it's probably nothing they
probably just forgot it but if someone
is gonna commit a terrorist act at an
airport you know if they're gonna try to
blow up an airport that's what they're
gonna do it's what the Boston bombers
did they took a book bag left in the
crowd you see someone doing something
like that you know tell someone it's
just it's better safe than sorry so just
to be aware of those kinds of things
things that are truly out of place
someone just walking into a room is not
out of place someone walking into a
theater with a book bag that's out of
place so be aware of that right and and
so yeah I think that I think it's a good
idea to be they it's unfortunate we have
to live that way
but we do and I don't think it should
make us it doesn't mean we never leave
the house just means that we have the
appropriate amount of caution and as far
as you said it you said about having
armed guards and so on I'm all for that
I think churches should have security I
think that yeah I think I think big
buildings with lots of malls and those
sorts of things they should have
security I don't think the government
should come in and do like a TSA type of
thing for every single building in the
country obviously
now is where you get to the infringement
of Liberty that cubie was talking about
but these places
I think should it be a good idea for
them to on their own look into security
because the cops can't always be there
in 30 seconds cops got there in 30
seconds in Dayton Ohio and if they had
if they if it had took in the cops if it
if it had taken the cops two minutes to
get there there'd be hundreds of people
dead possibly so you can't always rely
on the cops being there in 30 seconds
and even if they are there in 30 seconds
that might not be enough to save you so
that's why we should just be aware and
cautious and and able to defend
ourselves all right
heavy subjects difficult subjects today
on the show but that's just what needed
to be discussed so thanks everybody for
watching
god speed in El Paso Texas and eco
fascists slaughtered 20 people in a
shopping mall shooting the next day in
Dayton Ohio a socialist Satanist leftist
slaughtered nine including his own
sister at a bar leftist partisans rushed
to blame Trump and conservatives
conservatives eager to fight the unfair
attacks try to disavow any connection
whatsoever to the ideology of the el
paso shooter we will examine the reality
there are very terrible people on both
sides check it out on the Michael Noel's
show